hallo freunde und herzlich willkommen zu
einem ganz spontan video heute abend du
jetzt sicherlich etwas soll das mit
let's play pokal titel und vor allem was
wir luca di luca kann doch nicht mal
peak von caro unterscheiden ich bin beim
netzwerk poker pokerstars de c t ausgabe
am samstag also morgen um 18 uhr dabei
das ist an alle die sich wissen ist es
so eine charity-veranstaltung also jetzt
nicht irgendwas wo ich zehn millionen
euro dafür bekommen dass ich daran
teilnehme sondern einfach es geht darum
man pokert und der gewinner bekommt
quasi 2000 euro die allerdings nicht für
sich bekommt sondern die an eine
organisation seiner wahl spenden kann
bei mir ist das die r gemeinde kurz
bielefeld ist sonder heilsarmee also die
kümmern sich darum wenn beispielsweise
im winter leute auf der straße sitzen
und nichts warmes zu trinken haben oder
so und jedenfalls kann ich zwar bisher
noch nicht pokern aber wenn ich gewinnen
sollte werde ich das geld auf jeden fall
dahin spenden weil ich weiß dass es da
gut aufgehoben ist und nicht irgendwie
nochmal soll jedenfalls dies diesmal die
jubiläumsausgabe also die zehnte ausgabe
von let's play poker und da kommen die
eventuell so einige specials auf euch zu
ich weiß nicht vielleicht schon sagen
darf aber wie bei jedem let's play poker
ist es auch so dass jeder wieder so eine
art mitbringsel hat ich weiß dass sturm
war für beispielsweise sondern nütze
dabei hat ich hab mir gedacht ich nehme
einfach diese ganz alte webcam mit der
ich ganz damals meine videos
aufgezeichnet habe die nehme ich einfach
mit unterschreibt euch das und der
gewinner kann dann einfach wenn ihr euch
das morgen anschaut um 18 uhr wird durch
übertragen
kant könnt ihr mit etwas glück und den
infos ihr dann dort gegeben bekommt das
sicherlich irgendwie gewinnen falls wir
das ganze auf youtube live übertragen
das habt ihr eventuell schon beim
webvideo preis mitbekommen oder bei
einer vom partner veranstaltungen also
nicht auf myvideo sondern auf youtube
definierten link dazu in der
beschreibung befindet auf den youtube
kanal in der beschreibung und allgemein
alles umsonst hoffe ich dass wir morgen
dabei sein
am samstag um 18 uhr
auf dem ftp kanal who